before this vid starts just letting u know i bought all my subs
Check—links in the description.
peek
hold-- OH —[screams]
♪ cut my life into pieces ♪
[screams]
Hey, how's it goin'?
Ah, bros.
Got a new setup. It's pretty cool.
Look, I can do this.
two-thousand fourteen PewDiePie
I can do this all day. [chuckles]
No, it's pretty good. I like it. I like the quality.
I want quality in my videos guys.
Just understand that is in sacrifice
for better content! we're going to play a video game.
I know, I know it's been
a couple days. Pretty crazy.
[mocking voice] But Pewds, I thought you hated video games?
[muffled swearing]
This one looks like it's quite good so
let's check it out.
It's called Home Sweet Home
Alabama.
♪ Where the skies are so blue. ♪
That's the only song I know how to play on a guitar.
I would love to play for you sometime
but not today.
We're playing this game.
Oh it's me.
Except my dog wakes me up.
Who? What? Hey!
This is cool! Heh hey!
I thought—
Ah, ah, I thought Jane was here.
I thought I— heh.
I always just judge horrifically all the judge actors—
sorry all the voice actors
even though clearly like
I'm the worst fucking one.
WHAT ARE all th-these things! [laughs]
Hey! Flashlight! Ok, interesting.
Yeah that's— not that cool!
Ok? maybe you know the voice acting is
fine but the writing is a bit shit.
Alright? If I saw a flash I'd be like
Oh I flashlight! How [chuckles]
How conveniently placed!
Oh gee! I hope no one scares me next!
This is clearly set up by Jane.
Looks like I need to find a new wife!
You piece-of-shit chair! You look at me like
that once again and I will fuck you.
[sighs] Oh I will!
Alright.
Making my way downtown.
I don't—I don't know!
get out of here asking the same i love
the voice is beautiful.
How could i get out of here where am I
Dude you're about to die bitch -- oh is this the P.T
game that just goes around in circles?
Let's find out.
I see they're playing jacksepticeye
on the radio.
No thanks uh-oh ok I need a key. Ah, there's the key
tab description a normal key for um ok
well thanks for wasting my time that
There we go we did it
another creepy horror corridor
makes my nipples hard which is
always good about being Swedish you know
one of those perks-- OoOoh JESUS
nonono NO NO NO hehNO NO
if you see a creepy guy around the
corner hey shut the fuck up
shut the fuck up you don't yell you just
you creep around like this wait a m--
oh shit i thought-- I thought that was [chuckles]
person it's just the garbage bag! HELLO?
run all right
I don't like where this is going bros
this is actually creepy [HEEUUP] that was not
me being scared i just took a breaTH
really fast because i wanted to shut the
fuck up
I don't get scared pussy-ass games I'm not
a fucking pussy, i'm a swedish viking thank you
very much i'm going to die i would check
here that's like if this was a horror
scenario always check under the stairs
because people will--will-- they'll wait there
and then you walk through and they'll
sneak up behind you and you'll get
scared shit alright i know these things
i'm a horror game expert there was a guy
down there ..... bitch you're
fucking me over and I don't appreciate
it.
can I --light doesn't work HELLO? mate you
know what we just hit me it might be
Santa Claus and I've always wanted to meet
that guy
Well Santa's got a
great ass i gotta say man daamn where did
she go
OOH!! [Totally not-scared chuckle]
maybe a little bit more emotion would be good
[Mocking] HUH! That's blood
where did he g-- AAH that's ainsley [chuckles]
keep playing their
interesting game
all right well we got a lot of blood
now it could be cranberry juice so the
fact that he just went to the conclusion
that it was blood without tasting it [smacks lips]
I find that a lil - a lil offensive okay
clearly
I -- listen, the only thing that
that happened here is that you need to
find another day job alright there we go
what happened here where is-
oh shit AW - NO
What the fuck is this?
I think I- I think I'm supposed to run
OOOH - Fuuueeuuckk - fuckfuckfuckNOO [screams]
[manliest scream]
that gave me goosebumps man! Jesus christ
that was -- I'm getting too old for
this
like I can't keep playing horror games
hey you hey how you may ask why did you
buy that shirt? oh my god are those yeezes?
alright, we gonna run we gonna run
shit fuck fuck--
WHAT? what happened? I think i died again.
home sweet home more like this place
looks like shit and I got a bad offer on
this place. GOT 'EM that was good joke. Right?!
heh [mocking] ohmygod! what the-what da fock is dis dude?
Hey here we go!
Oh no we gotta hide! I hate hiding! Goddamn it!
She can't see me if i make a face
Is the tongue helping? I can't tell.
You know, it's quite ironic--
is she pissing on the fucking wall?
what a fucking bitch! just pissed on my
wall? I was going to say it's quite ironic
for the first time a girl is chasing me
maybe she doesn't wanna you know [clicks tongue] maybe
she does! anyway I think we will go
through this urine portal alright that
urine portal doesn't seem (Stops to sayDAMN DANIEL)
where's the way out
well clearly the urine portal will set
us free (Yes Absolutely)
so let's check this out oh what was that? ...*5 seconds later reaction* A BUCKET??!
my god
yeah that'll do the trick listen you
want to build up the scares you can't
just throw a fucking naked lady at me (but i thought you like the pewdiepie ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°))
and then be like; BUCKET!!!!
should have had the bucket before is what
i'm tryna say..
cut my life
into pieces (THIS IS MY CHOCOLATE BAR!)
hey how convenient that didnt take long. i love that about
games as soon as you need something you'll find i-- OH SHIT SHE'S URINATING EVERYONE
"it's chained" I KNOW ITS FUCKING CHAINED YA FUCKIN' MORON (Ya Tell Them Pewds! ) THE URINE D LADY IS COMING!!!! (uh oh ._.)
BITCH!
Got Em x2    Works Every Time
Jesus Christ fucking hell what is happening i'm
actually scared what the hell IS THAT
STEPHONO oh my gosh STEPHONO [CHUCKLES]
can't believe I'm still fucking playing horror games
2017 everyone Jesus Christ
this can't be healthy
ok ok CAN YOU STOP peeing on the wall
that's weird
alright which one did you going i guess
i'll go in this one BIIIITCH! Hey are we back where
we were in the beginning? uhhhh what is
happening i am confused now I guess I'll
take a shit
no? well then I don't know what I'm doing
[startled Swedish curses] HOO did not get scared that was
not a jump [Dudebro laugh] try not to get scared
challenge..... didn't work
that was not me being scared that was me
reacting in the Swedish kungfu defense
thank you very much fuck you you don't
know you don't know our secret
what the-- who keep a fucking urine in ok i guess i'm
in the urine now... you know what that's
actually pretty smart
what happened heh ok can't get out of the oh
I'm in an urine everyone! :D alright
anyway how do i get out of here
hey took a little-- took a little
bunny hop there. Nice. okay suppose we go let's
go through here and now if we run into
that bitch we know where to hide
ok which room is this? OH Fuck.
[Sings] Noooot oookaay.. I'm not okay
Excuse me? Okay it's closed
110 okay we're walking in
in circles now aren't we
because this is the bathroom yeah fuck I'm a bit
confused at this point not sure what I'm
what the f--
hey ah fucking bitch don't you just hate
when wood is blocking the way?
ok let's just be careful we can do this
hold my hand can do this with the lens
now does it look like we're holding
hands?
it's just a cute lil moment that we're
having together can't really I can't
really play at-- fuck all alright, listen
hold your own fucking hand
what do you want me to say ? alright bitch
went in here..... i think "Pardonne-moi.."  Mad
Mademoiselle (sorry girl in French) but uuhhh
where da dead bitch go? what I'm
looking for
hey I don't think we've been in here oh
alright alright getting a lil scared
cuz it was here that the got quiet all the sudden hello hello
hello hello
alright how's everyone doing uh-huh okay
well I want to make a period joke but at
the same time I don't think it's a HEY
hey look at that
a strange-looking doll full of nails
great promise I will never do that again
and a voodoo of curse
have you ever hated someone so much
actually you know what let me do this in
Jacksepticeye voice "have you ever hated
someone so much that you want you to 60 make
agonosing pain? THIS MAGIC IS FOR YOU!
With this you can bewitch nails in
the stomach of your enemy causing them
extreme pain [Jack's slap] like that there's black
magic has been passsed for generations to
generation instructions obtain personal
items from-- Alright I'm bored.
thank you for that appreciate your input
and you still need an axe the next and
i'm not talking about the deodorant ha haaa!
hey there we go perfect i'll take that
uh fuck fuck
be quiet hold my hand
OH- oh for fuck's sake that's my new carpet
ok we're fine Jesus Christ fucking
sweaty hands man where she going
haha i wish i had that effect just
fucking close its doors magically behind
me that'd be fucking cool as shit right
now we gotta be real real i'm
talking a lot because I'm nervous
alright? and I get nervous JUSt-- just we can do this
just shut the fuck up! gotta think of something
real nice like a really nice sausage
why did I go with that ok we're fine
we're fine we're going to live
we're going to live it's a miracle a
miracle everyone's going to live damn it
going to get out of here and i'm going
to start a YouTube channel where I play
only horror games -- ah fuck [Mocks pukes]
smells like rotten Tators in here. OH NO this is bad ohmygod
someone has been farting freely here, that's real fucking bad
oh shit it's her! How does she keep teleporting?
So annoying
ok I think wewewe we must be getting real
fuckin close at this point
come on I don't know why the tongue thing
alright?
don't ask! come on, i can do this
oh my god was this where she was?
voodoo enchantment~ morevoodoo shit! Fuck that
hello? aw fuck
ok sounded fun
GO IN GO IN!
no :( I just want to go home
hey I'm fine what about that they would PUBURU BUPUPU RUPUPU~~!
EU EUGH it's fuckin disgusting
DISGUSTING! What? what is this?
maybe we just -- this could be
UH OH UH OH OH NO! AH!
The Doors jammed FUCKA MAKA fon
okay that's fine Oh bitch is coming
Bitch is coming back
Fucking Jesus Eugh
DISGUSTING
how does she keep knowing where I am?
I don't understand
ok we're fine
we are fine. She's just breathing really
loudly.. might wanna get-- might want
to get that checked, honey
ok we're fine excellent
PABARAPA PAPAPARA!~~~
PAPAROW
Peak.. Hold--OH AAHHHH CUT MY LIFE IN 2 PIECES AHHH
NOOOOO no!
That's fucking right!
HA HAAA! when in doubt; scream like a bitch and
I'm just full of life advice today guys
It's free free. Don't worry about it! Hold right click and--
OOHH I see I see okay
hello? Hello bros, ok we did it alright alright
I hear a lot of breathing action going on over here
oh fuck me Jesus fucking christ
oh fuck fuck fuck you in the
fucking dick hole!
why do I say these horrible things I
don't like this I don't like this at all
come on Felix you can fucking do this
fucking shit fuck you fuck this game!
what does she breathe so much
ok alright i'm know I'm being quite I'm just
kind of nervouuus -- Dat ass look at that
ass, Boy
OH GOD she heard me! Are you doing squats?
damn girl! who's your daddy? I don't know
That doesn't relate to anything
ok alright we do we got?
great all right what -- what about in
here the creepy toilet; the men's toilet
I find that a little bit sexist by the
way that the guys toilet looks like shit
that's not necessarily true. i'm a guy
and I find myself to be very clean in my asshole
thank you very much video games! :) oh fuck
ok I don't want to die now I really don't
okay we just gotta wait for that biyutch
fuck a duck! don't fuck a duck that was
not a life advice! It was a life hack :D
don't turn don't turn -- Euuu [Swears in Swedish]
[Continues swearing]
ok we're here now, for no reason, great
this is it! Holy fucking shit
We did it!!
holy fucking shit hole
this is what we needed?
A fuse! Yes I've got it MHNNNNGGG
now we just gotta fucking go back.
I'm hiding!
I Don't trust this fucking game!
[Awkward wait time while background weirdo chants]
IS JACKSEPTICEYE PLAYING AGAIN?
Fucking awesome song!
Shut the fuck up! Aw fuck!
ok here we go!
She didn't see me!! She didn't see me!
[Anxious wait while she heavy breathes]
going we're going we're going
everybody's going everybody say Shalala
Hey to you, ya know, but that was nice then Britta
that you're gonna get to go on vacation now, Britta. aa well for fucking hell how nice
Ah well then we push the button here then Britta,  then it go so damn good ya'know.
put in that fuse there then ye'know. That'll solve it, no problems.
Then you can go to Mallorca and have it damn nice.
what's that fuck am I saying? (That's what we're thinking)
GOOO GOOO GOOOOOOOO
CUT MY LIFE INTO PIECES WHEN IS THIS GAME OVER
Hello? Oh oh oh Aw AWW
AW AW AW FUUCK AWWW FUUCCKK
FUUCCKKK MAYN
bitch is running! RUUUUNNNNN
COME ON MAAYYNNN
FUCK YOU FURNITURE WHAT DA FUCK
DID I DO TO YOOOOUUUUUU
THAT'S THE WAAAY AAHHH FUUUCK
EUUUUUUUHHHH
Aw fuck she's gonna fucking-- OHH
JESUS CHRIST!! Noo!
Ugh I can't no please don't tell--
*sobs* HEEEUUPPPP *sobs*
oh thank God I'm sweating I'm fucking sweating
(Sweating)
like a fucked-up we did it we did it
partner
thanks for being my Speeecial friend
Speeciaaalll friend now that i know you~~
now that you know me~~
TIILLLL the end of time~~
We will alwaayys beeee~~~~
Ains--OHMYGOD AN AINSLEY :D
Alright!! that was a really cool
horror game i really enjoyed it
did you like it? Let me know in the
comments down below
I thought it was pretty cool despite
some flaws but it's a demo so maybe
check out the full version when it's
done. I know I haven't done ma-
many gameplays place but I always enjoy doing one-offs else like this
resident evil 7 is coming out very soon
So i'm definitely going to be playing that
as well if you enjoyed these
horror type of stuff let me know
I appreciate your feedback
here's another video if you want to
watch another one and as always
kisses *muah* annd brofist!! (Subscribe)
I'm just gonna hang around for you to
fucking actually click
do it
GREAT